hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
gonna be my agents of shield episode 17
video since there's like a whole bunch
of Avengers news and stuff going on
around the premiere and phase 3 I'm
gonna try and work that into so the
video be just like a little bit
different from my normal format what
I'll do is I'll just talk about each of
the big running plot lines and then I'll
move into related Marvel Avengers stuff
so here we go just careful for spoilers
in case you haven't seen the episode yet
starting with Coulson's secret army I
think it's pretty clear here that
Coulson has been building infrastructure
for new inhuman people that he expects
to find the reason I think the real
shield wants to get their hands on the
tool box is because it has information
on where all these people are the
Coulson's targeted and where all his
bases are and just to take it a step
further I really do think that they're
trying to track down the people so the
real shield are trying to find the
super-powered people yeah it's a big
deal that Coulson's stockpiling supplies
weapons but I think the real shield is
more worried about the Inhumans than
they are about the bases themselves what
I think is gonna happen is is that
during age of Ultron we'll get a little
more context as for why all these bases
are necessary they'll do most of the
explaining on agents of shield like
throughout the rest of the season we'll
find out exactly what Coulson's doing
but I think age of Ultron in the movie
it'll add some context to that so it'll
make a little more sense especially
giving us Nick Fury's perspective on the
whole thing
they are building it out so that you
don't have to go see the movie to
understand what's going on an agents of
shield and and vice versa but they do
kind of work together to create a little
more context I also think all this
Coulson secret Inhumans base Deathlok
technology stuff is gonna tie in with
the spin-off show they said that the
remaining episodes this season will set
up what's happening in the spin-off show
so it'll all make sense by the time we
get to the end of the season as you
probably guess from the NTS or to Fitz
will totally join up with Coulson and
he'll totally shake the tail I love the
way hunter tees like this big WTF moment
that we never saw is there a dryer in
that bathroom yes you're gonna be okay
mate sometimes those are the best
moments the ones that you don't see like
your brain just imagine something crazy
happening so jumping over to the
Inhumans Skye finally meets her mother
and plays with the powers a little bit
I've said it before I think this real
shield versus shield stuff will figure
into Captain America Civil War it seems
like they're teasing a civil war inside
the in human society too Skye's mother
explains they're very strict rules
and how people would get really pissed
and they found out that jiying
was Skye's mother because she's the one
that created the rules about who gets to
take in the Terrigen mists they did a
really good job of tying that to the
agent may plot the family dinner also
very touching
I think sky was being genuine she was
she was happy to have dinner with her
mother and father even though she still
hates her father
there was a small Easter Egg for
daredevil in here because it seems like
sky and daredevil stayed at the same
orphanage for a period of time although
daredevil is a little bit older Skye
said she's 26 it made it a big deal to
say what her birthday was which is kind
of funny Matt Murdock and the timeline
right now and I think that daredevil and
agents of shield are running
concurrently right now like relatively
in the same time frame he's closer to
like 28 29 so he's like a little bit
older so they could have been at the
orphanage at the same time and there's
always a big question I said like what
things get to crossover with other
things
I think the ABC shows and the Netflix
shows have high potential for crossover
it's much easier than say crossing
daredevil over with the movies Lincoln
showing up at the end was a lot of fun
too because he realized that Raina is
clairvoyant which is a nice twist on
Garrett in season one she kept talking
about the clairvoyant surprise surprise
she turned out to be clairvoyant in real
life like a real clairvoyant not just
someone stealing secrets they're still
trying to figure out what rayna's powers
are so I think it'll go beyond
clairvoyance it won't just be that like
she'll probably have some sort of
physical ability to with her spikes
George RR Martin's said this really
interesting thing about the way you
build out super-powered characters he
said you have to balance stats otherwise
it becomes completely ridiculous he was
talking about board games like like
role-playing board games
so like if a character is really big and
really strong they're probably not very
dexterous they probably don't have very
strong magical resistance abilities if a
character's say like a dwarf with a lot
of physical deformities and can't move
really fast he probably has very strong
magic so by that logic Raina being
extremely disfigured probably has very
powerful abilities I'm interested to see
if there is some sort of civil war
that's going on inside the in human
society and it positions Raina and
Gordon on one side and Lincoln Skye and
her mother on another side it seems like
Lincoln is a pretty nice guy I don't
think he's gonna sell Skye out it's
unclear as to whether or not he knows
jiying is Skye's mother it seems like he
doesn't but based on the way that the
show has presented him it
seems like they want us to think of him
as a friend as opposed to Gordon who's a
little more neutral it seems like he
favors Reyna but he's gonna be taking
care of her emotionally and taking care
of her training
so if Reyna hates sky it would stand to
reason that Gordon would support Rayna
over sky we'll see how that develops
because it seems like that in humans
afterlife place is just like a hornet's
nest waiting to explode so jumping to
the agent may plotline we find out all
about her past why it is she has such
crazy PTSD she killed a child admittedly
a crazy powerful child that she had to
kill but it was so much fun seeing her
so decompressed like like seeing the
mundane agent may she's still very
powerful still badass fighter but she
didn't have that edge that she has in
the present-day scenes if you're a
little confused as to what was going on
the mother wasn't inhuman who had a
daughter who wanted her daughter to be
able to take in the Terrigen mists as
her birthright giant Skye's mother
detected a darkness quote-unquote
detected that the child was crazy so she
was like nope so she wanted to prevent
that so the mother ran away with the
child stole some Terrigen crystals and
the child got crazy psionic abilities
you could think of it as a reference to
Maximus the mad who's black bolts crazy
brother and has mad psionic abilities we
do get to see like the end point like
she ends up at the desk where we see her
at at the beginning of season one so it
was a nice way to tie it back to the
beginning here's my big question for you
guys you know what was your favorite
moment from the episode and are there
any other characters on this show who we
haven't seen a flashback for that you
really want to see one the other really
tortured person we saw flashback 4 was
Ward we learned all about his crazy
family I think he's actually back next
week so be sure to subscribe to get that
video it's gonna be a lot of fun I
really like the direction that Ward's
character is taken he is so much more
fun than he was in season 1 so moving
into like Avengers phase 3 stuff there
was a whole bunch of stuff that's been
said because age of Ultron is coming out
they're doing press conferences so I'm
gonna start with the Hulk movie Mark
Ruffalo just explained why there is no
Hulk movie on the books right now Marvel
wants to do and they will do one
eventually it's just a matter of time
he said that Universal technically still
has the legal rights
that's why Marvel hasn't attempted one
so far sidenote
Joss Whedon also wanted to make Avengers
2 much more about the Hulk and Hawkeye
so he asked the other phase 2 directors
to not feature those characters just
because he's gonna spend so much
time on them so it's just a matter of
time till Marvel gets the rights back
and they can actually do a solo Hulk
film but by that time Mark Ruffalo might
have completed his contract so unless he
reads after his contract is up his sixth
picture contract we might see another
actor in a solo Hulk film the actors
that are closest to completing their
contracts are Chris Hemsworth and Chris
Evans they have three pictures each left
and they're already on the books it's
like their next solo film and then the
two Avengers films what I'm expecting is
that of the original Avengers class like
the original actors to play like these
big Avengers characters most of them
will reassign their contracts but one or
two of them will probably leave you have
to remember that like right now we have
almost like seven eight-nine Avenger
characters that's it that's a lot so
they're not all gonna stick around
forever speaking of New Avengers there
are details on the spider-man character
Kevin Feige was going on and on about
spider-man and Captain Marvel
Feige was really nice and he talked
about like the role of the Inhumans on
the TV show versus the Inhumans in the
movies what he said is is that based on
the budgets and the things that you
could do on TV you could pretty much
guess what we're not gonna see on the TV
show mainly the royal family in at land
outside of that they'll completely
explore in human society like the inner
workings of that set things up so that
there is a context whenever the solo
movie comes and we see all the big
spectacle stuff has for spider-man I
think everybody knows at this point that
we're gonna be seeing like a super young
version of him the costume itself will
be much more primitive he said that in
in the timeline of the movies right now
there is a little kid spider-man like a
high school spider-man swinging around
New York City that people just don't
know about yet and when I say people I
mean characters like Matt Murdock Tony
Stark like the people inside the Marvel
Universe the characters what they're
gonna do is focus much more on the
classic wit of the Peter Parker
character much more so than the other
films have ever done to other spider-man
films so this will be the funniest most
wisecracking ly awesome spider-man
you've ever seen before going forward
Chris Evans went on to say that he
really wants Captain America to be a
mentor to this young spider-man
character when we get to Captain
American Civil War he will be in the
movie spider-man is gonna be in Civil
War we just don't know how much we also
know some stuff about Captain Marvel
orig
she was supposed to have a cameo in
Avengers 2 but they just they cut her
out for practical reasons Kevin Feige
just said that they knew they were gonna
do Captain Marvel solo film and they
already had so many characters in
Avengers 2 that they were just like okay
let's simplify this a little bit so it
doesn't get too crazy so they actually
shot around planned cameos for her like
they were gonna like CG her in in the
background it's just amazing how much
you can change a movie after you've
already shot it they do have a writer
Nicole Pearlman who was the one who
initially developed the guardians of the
galaxy movie before James Gunn came on
and ended his version of the script
she's gonna be writing Captain Marvel
with another person just as a reminder
Batman vs Superman teaser supposed to
drop tomorrow I'll totally do a video
for it and there's supposed to be a new
Star Wars Force awakens trailer in Star
Wars Episode seven after I get through
all that stuff there totally be new
daredevil so hopefully a new daredevil
by like Friday or Saturday what you guys
wait for all that stuff you can click
here for the latest ant-man trailer and
you can click here for last night's
episode of the flash thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight
you